se tiende un puente de migración legal
desde Guatemala hacia Estados Unidos a
partir de esta semana comenzó el plan
piloto con el cual los nacionales del
convenio centroamericano sea 4 es decir
los ciudadanos de Guatemala El Salvador
Honduras y Nicaragua podrán solicitar
asilo u obtener una visa para Vivir de
manera legal en Estados Unidos y para
ellos ya está habilitado el portal
movilidad segura.org quienes Allí se
inscriban deberán calificar a una de las
vidas regulares de migración bien sea la
de reunificación Familiar o recordemos
con la reciente implementación de la
política migratoria del título 8 deberán
demostrar un verdadero miedo por
persecución política o judicial o de
violencia que es una realidad muy común
que afecta a estos países
Centroamericanos donde están instalados
gobiernos autocráticos donde se denuncia
que hay acecho judicial donde operan
clandestinamente las pandillas conocidas
como las maras quienes estén inscritos
quienes hayan calificado podrán entonces
agendar una cita presencial en una de
las oficinas de movilidad aquí en
Guatemala exponer su caso aunque esto no
garantiza que les vayan a probar la
migración legal Eso sí hay voces
escépticas como las de los directores de
las oficinas de las casas del migrante
quienes aseguran que se está trasladando
un problema de congestión migratoria que
sufren actualmente México y Estados
Unidos en sus fronteras está viniéndose
entonces para Guatemala y se prevé que
estas oficinas de movilidad seguras se
atiborren de migrantes